.
THEY WANT TO FINOUHA MAKRE HPEOT
MINWIDY IN
TH GOINGO FACE
JUSTICE?
SMEAN, WE'RE NGIN.AYER
DEFINITELY HAVE TO
RESPONTY FOR THEIRBEHAVIORS.ALS.
A COUP, THEY TRIED TO -- TK PLA.
THEY TRIED TO JU TOTALLYTLE DEM.
HE PEOPLE WITH
THE OING TO BE
BROUGHT TO>> YOU'RE TALKING ABO
F THITATES AND ANY
HELD A? KNOW,SSA,MAY, BN CE THE
ACTUALLY
HE TOLD YOU IN NOVEMR OF
WORKING IN THE WHITESE. E D OUN
YOU BELILOTHIS G
HE ACTUALLY ADS
CONFERENCE WHEN HE WAS SPEAKING
ABOUT CORONAVIFING ROOM, HE ACT
M T D THIS I
GOING TO TAKE DO
PUBLIC ABOUT A MANHOT AND
COULDN'T DAT DON
THE TIF OUHISTORY,
WHISYOU KN, ALLOW PEACEFUL TRAND
ALLOW WHE CTNTO OF
THING REALLY
ARO ME.
CI O SHRUNK T COUP OS, A
DRAMIC, IVANKA,
GOODD, PE ADVICE FROM WERE NOT
D.
ENCE A
VERYRY I WASASSADOR IN
FEET FROM INTOHOCKED MUF
AR THES>> I WANT TON O TH
, THE PRESIDENENEKAP.ON QUESTIO
HELLSECONDLY,
WE'RE IN
YOLIN THE REALTHE MIDWEST.
ACOE PEOPLE IN THIS NATION RIG
THE CONFE PANDEMICF THIS
ND QUI FRANKLY
THE CAVALI ATTITUDE THAN
IN THE ELITEHA OF EPEOPLE AND
ROUND THIS COUNTRY,
WHETHER THEY'RE RULE HOODS,
URBAN HOODS ORN HOODS,
IS REAL.
THE GAS PRICES IN CALIFORNIA,
RR EXAMPLE, ARE HIGHER THAN TH
OHIO YOU'RE PAYING ALMOST $6.
THERE ARE GSN
I G TO STRAT FIC IST DR. DEREK O
DERSTAND
INATE PO -
DO AS NATN
TO DRIVEN THL OF P
THATG INS
ENT AFFORD
THEIR FOOD'T AFFORD
GAS?
YOU HAVE T
CAN'T AFFORD GAS.
THE FED CAN BE AR,
THEY HERE.O SE RATES.
THEY CANUAMP IN HERE
AND DO SOMETHING S HAS TO
BE D
>> AND SHE'S DOING -- I AGREE
U JUST SAID.
GHTE.
THWH F T
THEY K SHOULD HAVE KNOWN.
THE FED RAISINFLN RATES.STOP SP.
THANK GOD FOE MANCHIN.
>> OH,ORT GOING TO THANK GOD --
ES,  ARE
RESPECTFULLY
WAS $9 TRILLION.
WE'RE AT $30N.WE CAN'T KEEP SPE
SP
>> WE HAVE0 SECONDS LEFT.
>> EXCELLENT MESSENGER
M EDS W McCONAUGHEY TO COME OUT
AND  ECONOMY